cet hiver alors invité de l'émission le
grand jury sur lci que françois bayrou
s'est exprimé en faveur d'un plan
marshall dans le but de reconstruire
notre économie en raison de la crise
sanitaire qui a grandement détruit le
pays
si on veut sauver le modèle social
français
alors il faut faire de l'économique et
de l'économique de reconquête à veut
dire que par exemple ce qu'il faut une
contribution exceptionnelle des plus
riches en période de covin s'il fallait
pourquoi pas dans le cadre de ce plan
l'idée de taxer davantage les français
les plus riches pour faire repartir
l'économie est abordée et pour le
président du modem
la notion de riches n'est apparemment
pas la même que tout le monde si vous le
dites sk4000 euros en est riche
ma réponse est non des propos qui n'ont
pas choqué quand plateau mais aussi sur
les réseaux
on ne vit vraiment pas dans le même
monde alors êtes vous d'accord avec
françois beihong ça fait énormément
réagir jouer qu'on en parle bien sûr et
après bien sûr on va parler de 2,2 de ce
livre est notre témoin alors nicolas
pernikoff non quand vous savez que le
salaire médian on sait 1750 euros et
qu'il doit y avoir les 9 10 % des gens
qui doivent gagner 4000 euros et plus
tenir ce genre de propos quand vous avez
sa fonction et qui les rend plus censé
travailler pour sortir notre pays de la
crise
je trouve ça assez inquiétant et puis
surtout qu'il ya un problème de liens
affectifs entre les politiques et les
français qu'il a quand vous déclarez
s'abreuver fini définitivement quoi liés
aux gens tombent c'est complètement
démago est ce que tu me dis que le
salaire médian c'est 1750 euros le
salaire moyen soit un gain de 4 mille
euros mon départ il faut arrêter d'être
hypocrite quand vous vivez dans une
grande ville le moindre loyer 6000 euros
1200 1500 euros vous avez des charges
avait des frais il vous reste coi 500
euros pour vivre c'est très bien vous
pouvez les secteurs auront un loyer dans
une grande vivre une vie minimale mais
j'avais de la ville et bien sûr que si
j'avais de la vie c'est ça sera regardé
euros c'est énorme déjà
voir des règles que tu dis nicolaï et
voilà on qui au fil correctement mais on
n'est pas aux riches qu'est ce que ça
veut dire être riche
être riche c'est faire ce qu'on veut
tout le temps elle est tout le temps
restaurant s'acheter des belles voitures
etc
désolé avec 4000 euros bruts en plus on
vit pas comme ça désole gilles verdez à
une énorme faute politique et c'est une
monstruosité vous rendez compte tous les
gens qui entendent ça alors après il a
essayé de se reprendre
oui je parlais que de 4000 pour un
ménage 2000 plus de mille parce qu'il
s'est rendu compte de ce qu'il a dit
mais c'est honteux et pour répondre à
guillaume 3470 euros par mois après
impôts voilà le seuil de richesse en
france donc évidemment qu'on est riche à
4000 euros qui gagne s'il vous plaît ya
plein de gens qui dit parlant à paris
impossible de se loger en dessous de
1000 euros cd seule consolation béart
est que ce sont des chèques concrétions
délire bowie géraldine alors la richesse
mais je trouve que c'est relatif c'est à
dire les mecs team hm je pense que je
suis riche par rapport à plein de gens
qui nous regardent que vous êtes riche
dans votre coeur
les revers que je sens venir commencent
par rapport à vous n'en voyez encore une
fois vous mettez dans l'histoire de moi
ensuite la richesse alors une et bernard
montiel il prenait 82 euros justement le
pr bernard montiel la richesse et les
biens c'est la bière c'est la pierre
s'est fait d'être justement clarifier
servir c'est d'être propriétaire est ce
que la richesse ses fils et finalement
le salaire le salaire ça aléatoire on le
voit aujourd'hui on peut avoir un
problème il peut y avoir une crise on
peut se met à grimper le chômage donc en
fait ça c'est tout à fait aléatoire et
moi je suis d'accord avec guillaume je
préfère 100 fois la déclaration de
bayrou qui disent à une tête de celle de
hollande qui disait avec beaucoup de
démagogie cette fois ci à 4000 euros
on est riche ça je trouvais que c'était
une sorte de démagogie insupportable et
il a raison moi quand je vois qu'il ya
deux professeurs en milieu de carrière
qui gagne 5000 euros par mois à 2
j'estime que c'est pas des gens riches
estime que c'est des gens sains la faune
comme hyper qui vont de temps en temps
vacances qui gagnent leur enfant un
petit peu et à rien d'indécent
alors on va voir ce qu'on pense déjà les
téléspecteurs va faire déjà un petit
point non dean voilà un peu les gens ne
pense rien pour l'instant
voilà voyons pas elle vous d'accord non
c'est assez partagés bernard montiel le
plus riche d'entre nous mais quand vous
dites ça parce que benjamin est pas là
évidemment 4000 cda beaucoup d'argent
mais c'est ce que gagnent en général un
foyer et pour ça il s'est rattrapé l'a
compris que c'était d'abord une erreur
politique d'avoir dit ça évidemment que
c'est une erreur et s'est rattrapé par
la suite en disant que c'était parfois y
est vous dire deux personnes mais vous
oubliez jamais gagné il ya deux ans qui
n'est ni 4000 euros par mois aujourd'hui
les riches oui voyez de vies perdues ou
jean boiteux berdaoui stéphane mais je
rejoins exactement mot pour mot ce
qu'elle a dit ça veut rien dire 4000
euros à seul à deux en province ou à
paris en province effectivement suffit
très bien et 4000 euros dans une grande
ville tu vis pas du tout et catherine
euros parce que proto loger avec trois
enfants un loyer c'est minimum entre
1000 et 1500 euros dans un quartier pas
terrible donc ça veut rien dire cette
phrase ça veut rien dire mais en même
temps c'est bayrou quoi il veut rien
dire à chaque fois ayew retour l'invite
pour que pourquoi il est là c'est
surtout la question qu'est ce qui
représente quoi pour être la commissaire
il a été au gouvernement nommé par m
oui isabelle moi je trouve que le mot de
route que dis-je il est effectivement
honteux quand toi tu le dis parce qu'il
ya une grille des salaires métonymique
750 euros peugeot
oui mais c'est ça qu'on regrette c'est
que ces salaires là qui devrait être
monté une souris de tomorrow et quand
unis à paris c'est il ya qu'à paris que
les loyers sont chers nous allions ainsi
à nîmes à nice il ya plein de villes où
les loyers seraient très cher et 15000
euros tu est aisée mais tu n'es pas
riches devraient être convoqués riche on
est pauvre mais il n'ya plus de classe
de dire qu'avec quatre mille euros on
s'en sort pas dans une grande ville
c'est parfait avec 4000 euros tu t'en
sors dans une grande ville même avec un
gorille amine même avec un loyer à 1005
peut dire des gens qui touchent 1003 et
qui habitent dans des grandes villes ils
s'en sortent que avec 1003 mais après ce
qu'il dit là il parle me parle du foyer
comme a dit gilles donc ça fait 2000 et
2000 moi je pense qu'on n'est pas riche
à à 4000 euros parce qu'un temps relève
les impôts ils tracent trois mille 3000
trois tarifs
pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui décide de
prendre un jet comme ça du jour c'est
quelqu'un qui est sur un yacht l'été à
la plage c'est quelqu'un qui roule dans
des ferrari des porsche sassari si vous
pensiez benjamin castaldi mais je
pensais pas arriver bizarrement non je
tairai le nom pour des idées pour des
motifs il est là les experts du kof
[Rires]
casimir s'est dit vraiment être riche
d'avoir un yacht un avion et ça mais
enfin excuse moi on n'a pas besoin de
parler des super dur juste être riche
c'est pour avoir balancé que jamais des
fois pas besoin d'en avoir cinq une
belle voiture on te fait rire c'est 4000
par personne donc à wimille par exemple
tu peux accéder à la propriété tu vas
voir un crédit 2005 de 2000 même de 3000
pour pas le problème et tu peux partir
une fois deux fois trois fois en
vacances et ça suffit il faut faut pas
changer un foyer en foyer ne gagne pas
4000 euros par mois arrêtez de parler
car il ne vivait pas et tant mieux pour
vous grâce à ses fans et ses droits et
moi être riche
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas calculer son
budget le 15 août catherine horeau je
redis et je signe que c'est énorme pour
des gens vous voyez bien que de plus en
plus de gens qui doivent quitter paris
ne serait ce que pour le pouvoir d'achat
bien c'est à dire quand elle avait 1000
euros de côté et que vous êtes à 400 km
de paris vous vivez deux fois mieux
qu'un parisien mais moi j'habite à 50 de
paris je peux pas habitat par email
3 % d'accord pour envoyer ou non à 40 à
50 7% à 1